> All right.
Volume is good.
Hi everybody, we're going to start things
off with a little video of a web site that
has been called "very slick" by multiple media
out lites.
Virgin America, it's very fancy, cut down
on the number of screens that it takes you
to buy a plain ticket.
We're going to demo it in JAWS which is a
screen reader.
(Tab ... book link tab tab, tab, tab, tab,
tab, tab, I'm just tabbing, sign in link,
‑‑ sign up, links, tab, San Francisco,
liquidity, oh, I see that, Boston ‑‑ what
does that do San Francisco link ‑‑ okay,i
guess I'm departing from somewhere, I don't
know what I'm trying to book.
Tab, tab, Los Angeles Las ‑‑ paren, paren,
link, okay, I guess I'll just leave from Los
Angeles Las, but I don't know how the use
this web site, if I can't see it.
Now it kicked me all the way back to the top,
even though ‑‑ even though I should be
down the screen, oh, ‑‑ paren link ‑‑ there
was an alert there.
At the top of the screen, when something happened
I made a selection there was a big banner
at the top that said hey, you made a selection
if I moment a visual user I have no idea that
that occurred.
So now I've been scrolled further down the
page, this is part of a user experience that's
very visual, but I have no idea where I am
in this flow.
(I don't see Fort Lauderdale, that's somewhere
else on the screen.
(All cities link, tab ‑‑ that's not what)
I that's not what I'm trying to find, that's
frustrating.
‑‑ okay, I must be related the numbers
down below.
Tab, tab, tab, tab, add link, tab, tab, zero
‑‑ tab, add link, tab, tab, subtract link,
tab, tab,
>> still don't really know what I'm trying
to do here.
>> Shift tab, enter.
>> So there's another alert, I didn't hear
it.
>> Tab, tab, shift, tab, now I'm on the calendar
selection, ‑‑ continue with two adults,
‑‑ show my dates link, I'm skipping before
and after the calendar, and I can't figure
out how I'm going to book these dates, so
not only have I picked a destination and a
departure city that I didn't really want,
I just couldn't use this thing, that's really
unfortunate, really slick web site, not if
you're using a keyboard or a screen reader,
that's a good seg way.
What could improve that?
If it was accessible anyonee anybody could
use it.
A web site shouldn't drum to say oh, well
you can't see, well you're not going to fly
on virgin America.com.
We should talk about accessibility of accessibility,
out in the real world people are forgetting
about it.
Accessibility to me meanness my friends and
family can use any web site that I have created
or that I send out in a tweet or Facebook,
it also means that if I lost my eyesight or
hearing I would be able to continue to use
the apps and web sites that I used before.
Another way to think about it.
The actual definition here, accessibility
means that everyone can perceive, understand,
navigate and interact with the web and they
can contribute to the web.
So if you're building Dev tools or some tool
there are blind developers there, are people
of all different abilities, that think need
our help.
If you're the type of person that responds
more to numbers, here's some numbers for you
from from European disability forum.
80 million Europeans have disabilities, that's
fifteen percent of the population, according
to their figures, that's a lot of people.
We could think accessibility is about people,
it's about your neighbors, family, it could
be use in the future, we should be taking
care to make sure that user experience that
we create and the interfaces that we code
are accessible to everybody.
You might be thankful later that you actually
took some time.
Today I'm going to talk about JavaScript for
everyone.
And specificically, accessibility of accessibility
of JavaScript and DC framework, I'm a developer
at substantial in Seattle.
‑‑ design component, I'm going to have
a lot of Angular in my code today, it's not
my favorite or anything like that I just happen
to be most familiar with it.
I co‑chair for girl chair in Seattle.
It's way to give back the my computer and
support my fellow women in tech.
Oh, and my goal today, I should remember that,
is that I want to arm you with the ideas and
the concepts that you need to make your web
sites accessible and your JavaScripts applications,
this is very front end focused, obviously
very tied to HTML and CSS, we oar focusing
on the JavaScript delivery part of, that you're
creating HTML with JavaScript, we should know
what it takes to make that accessible.
The con noncal example for MVC framework is
. MVC the 2, the baseline of these frameworks
differs whether they're accessible how much
support they can give you, some of the ones
I've worked with bange bang bone, spine, ember,
I haven't used react, I'm curious about that,
if you have ideas about react accessibility
come find me, then famous, that have admitted
that they're not supporting accessibility
yet, it's a hard problem for them, they haven't
focused on from the start.
I would challenge you to consider whether
you need to use framework for a production
site that has admitted that it's not accessible.
It's irresponsible, so chose wisely.
We're going focus on the common aspects of
MVP frameworks that it doesn't really matter
which one you chose, the common things in
these framework s is that they're client rendered
applications you're using JavaScript to inject
HTML, make it interactive, you typically separate
your code into different concerns, models,
views, controllers, routers, whatever the
pattern is that you're using, it doesn't really
matter, it's the quality of your application,
it's client reverend, it's asin concurrent
resolution nows, and has happy responsive
interface, how do we make that accessible.
Are
you apps accessible?
It could depend on the framework, if you're
using famous, probably not, if you're using
ember or Angular that will give you little
help.
If you're trying to chose framework you should
consider the things that we're going to talk
about today.
I could depend on screen reader browser combination
that your end user is using to access your
site.
And then finally your code is the biggest
variable here, I have asterisks next to the
framework and your code being the things you
could potentially control to varying degree.
Your code, that's the thing you is the most
control over.
But you can also contribute back to the frameworks
on GitHub, that's what I'm doing with Angular,
try make t more accessible, get the framework
to help you more and do the heavy lifting.
If there's way to contribute back to the framework,
do it, it's awesome.
So the goal to reason that, you're probably
all sitting here today you want to know what
is it in single page applications that's challenging
with accessibility.
I have listed managed ARIA attributes, I have
it listed first because of the big push for
web components, custom controls in Angular
they there are directives, ember has custom
components, you're quiting custom HTML that
have no definition, no meaning, no states
no properties.
You want to uniKate to users of assistive
technology, screen reader, magny if Iers,
communicate in a non‑visual way the purpose
of your application and the purpose of it.
Enabling the keyboard, this is not rocket
science, not hard, yet we always forget about
I. Virgin America was a big offender of that,
when I tapped through page, no visual focus
style, no way for me to know where I was on
the page.
And then, we oar also going to talk about
handling focus, this is tied along with enabling
the keyboard, in a JavaScript MVP application
depending on your template solution you might
be updating your application by ripping out
parts of the DOM and putting them back.
If you're using a keyboard that can be a problem,
as we saw with virgin America when it changed
the careen we didn't get a page reload it
scrolled me further down the page but my focus
was jumped all the way to the top, for a keyboard
user, that's not fun user experience, it's
not what you would call "slick" if we're ripping
out the DOM and putting it back, we need to
guide the user through the experience by sending
their focus around, that's really useful thing
in JavaScript MVP applications, you should
remember that before creating these custom
controls or adding ARIA, you should try to
write meaningful HTML and native HTML, I'm
not going to ouch to on this much today in
MVP App we saw when there was a big alert
and it didn't tell me if I was a non‑visual
user you need to alert the user this thanks
are happening on the screen, maybe their focus
is on one part of the application and something
is happening elsewhere, it's filtering or
maybe they had an error in their form submission.
We need to actually tell the user that something
else is happening.
So,let's talk about ARIA, stands for accessible
rich internet applications, the idea is that
it's a set of attributes you use to expand
HTML's semantic vocabulary, you can fill in
the gaps where HTML ‑‑ you're creating
custom elements you have to define what those
are, if you think of a form input that has
properties, it could be disabled, it would
required.
In a screen reader, it's communicated that
is a form element.
If you're creating a custom element, you don't
get any of that for free, you can use area
to add some of that meaning.
The first core component of ARIA is the role,
you think of it as what does this thing do,
my example is I have aiv.
It has a style ‑‑ a Div ‑‑ you might
think that why isn't it just an image tag.
CSS background images have a few more options,
and maybe you want to make scaling background
images, in the real world this happens to
communicate the purpose of this Div, which
is presentation related, I can make it a more
one to one experience by communicating that
this is an image, if I add a role of image
to this D ivy all it has on it is a style
of background image.
This communicates a purpose, they can't see
the image, but at least they know it's an
image not just some empty Div sitting there.
The next piece in ARIA core components is
the state, the current condition of this particular
thing, I mention in a form input might be
required or disabled.
A state tends to change depending on the state
of the application, here I have a material
input, which is like a custom input tag, and
since it's a custom element, I can't make
use of the actual disabled attribute.
So, you might wonder why would I use ARIA,
if lease already a disabled attribute, it
only works on certain elements, if you're
creating a custom one you need to expand the
vocabulary, that item is disabled.
And then you can update it depending on what
the interface is doing.
And then, lastly if ARIA core components there
are core properties, they tendless often than
states, I have a Doner‑Kebab element, not
a taco butt son, it has an ARIA label, it's
a Doner‑Kebab, it might have Angelina Magmum
bringing us lunch.
No today ‑‑ it's a piece of off screen
piece of information that tells the use wharethis
thing is it's really useful.
Every form input needs a label, sometimes
you might not have label as part of your design,
either you could put a label element off screen
or add area label directly on the input and
add confection to a non‑visual user ‑‑ add
context to a non‑visual user.
Firstly the element types like we saw with
the image, there's headings, let's see what
else is there that you might use, there's
links, forms, where's some other ones, lists.
The idea with a role is it communicates what
the type of element is.
It will be announce in the a careen reader.
Secondly, roles can be used as landmarks,
by landmarks for a screen reader they can
jump around a page without having to use the
tab.
They could navigate through beige by navigation
elements or maybe you have a main element
indicating the main body of your document,
so those are useful to users who maybe aren't
using a mouse.
So you also want to start with native HTML
tags, you get a lot for free, attributes,
keyboard vents if it's an interactive control,
if you most use custom elements read the ARIA
documentation, which I have in my slides,
if you're using a certain role, what the expected
keyboard behavior is.
If it's a button, you expect it to be engaged
with the space bar, so those are things that
you need to know when a certain vole announce
in the a screen reader, that user who's expecting
it to behave in a certain way you will have
thought of that and you can bind the JavaScript
vents to make it work the way they expect.
Don't over do dew it there is such a thing
as too much ARIA, you want the simplest extras
possible, to communicate the state and properties
of your application at any given time.
One role that we should talk about is the
application role it might be tempting to put
this on your JavaScript MVC apps, because
they're applications but there's a concept
here in screen readers that you should know
about there are different modes, the detolt
is a virtual cursor this does not pass every
key back to browser directly, it's buffer
beteen user and browser, we talked about landmarks
there's a way screen reader users can navigate
a page using different key commands, the virtual
cursor handles those, if you disable it, you
have the ability to disable it, then you're
going to send every keyboard command directly
to the browser, if they're trying to navigate
by headings, they might not be able to.
You want to limit use of this to interactive
controls that are more advanced, that actually
mimic desktop applications specifically.
Unless you have a really good reason and you
know how how toous this role, just avoid it.
Especially don't put it on the body element,
even though it's tempting, I have an animated
give and just body rolling away if his responsibilities
because that's what you're probably go dog
if you use this role, meanwhile you're probably
going to be making your application unusable
to people with disabilities.
So how do you decide whether to use the application
role?
If I have a Sparkel party application, for
example, and it has a couple of advance things
in it like a kiss COBAL if you start dancing
it will spin the disco ball, it looks like
an application, it has a heading, button,
things that maybe the user would navigate
by heading, we don't want to disable the virtual
cursor, in the disco ball element, maybe I
could, it's probably going to cause more trouble
than it's worth.
I'm just going to leave it off.
One thing I did add in my pseudo code application
is inside of my disco ball element I have
a condition vas that will render some element
of the disco ball, how would the non‑visual
user know this is happening, how would I make
this interesting to someone who can't see
it I've add add paragraph that I can just
append text to, there's a concept called ARIA
live, this would be useful on virgin America.com,
when they had the banners on top, if they
added ARIA live element, off screen, it has
to be rendered, so it can't have display none,
if it's somewhere on the page, if it's polite
or assertive, differing levels of rudeness;
once you append text to the thing, it will
read it allowed on the screen reader, when
the disco ball starts turning we could send
an alert to the ARIA live region, all right,
when it stops you can stop dancing, if the
disco ball is not spinning why you dancing.
So, that's some ARIA stuff, let's talk about
the keyboard.
This is something that we forget quite often,
it's low hanging fruit, stuff that you can
do to really improve the state of the web.
The easiest thing you can do is add a tab
index, tab here I have on a Div it's not an
interactive control by default, swap it out
or some ember custom component something that
is not in the tab order.
By adding a tab index of 0 you add it.
Content editable is something you can add
to HTML and it does a similar thing.
If it has tab X of zero, I can tab on it.
If I add negative one it pulls it out of the
tab oridance oh, I can still use JavaScript
to script focus to it I's useful.
I will say avoid numbers higher than zero
what that means is that you're determining
the actual tab order of everything in your
page, upless you want to manage every single
tab index you can easily lose track and your
footer can come before everything else on
the page, if you use 0 it'll keep the natural
order of the HTML hierarchy.
Make a logical tab oridance e.
An example of what not to do.
I have see this all the time, and it's pretty
easy to fix, but I have a Divev that has a
CSS class on it.
And I'm using large here because it cuts down
on the amount of code I have to show you.
I can bind JavaScript directly on HTML.
It's not a judgment, it's really easy for
me to show it to you, but, you cold imagine
this abstracted into a special JavaScript
file with your framework of choice.
But, the click event that we found here, I
have this little hamburger button, if I click
it, it opens a menu.
But if I try to stab on to it the, I can't
get to it, I just can I want around every
element that has a tab index around everything.
Don't do that, if you have a hamburger menu
it should be in tab order, it should be a
button, not a Div.
How do we fix this if I have a button and
add a tab index to it, okay, it has a click,
you think this would work, but if I tab on
to it, like that's Whoo‑hoo, if I hit the
enter key, I can't engage this thing, which
is a bummer, what's up with that, that means
we can't see the spicy C hierarchyiuawha dancing
in the background, not cool.
How do we fix this now ‑‑ by adding tab
index, we can tab on to the dance button,
we had a role button, I want to communicate
this is a button to a non‑visual user, I
have the NN click the same, the extra step
because this is a custom element, I add tab
index to make it you could tab on to it.
It doesn't natively fire the key press vent
that we need.
If I add an NG key press and fire the same
event as a click vent all of a sudden I can
hit the space bar and we can dance.
All right, let's dance more after this, though,
because that's awesome.
So, one little last piece of low hanging fruit
that I would really love to see ‑‑ this
would of helped virgin America a lot.
Any element that has tab index, this is kind
of a pseudo select index here of tab index
of zero, any element that's in the tab order,
if you define a hover style in CSS define
a focus style right along with it.
Knock it out at the same time, super easy,
you, have to remember you can't focus on something
that you can't tab on to.
I know this is JSConf, but this is super easy
win, just do it.
You might be wondering why I'm wearing gold
pants, I don't know if you were wondering
about that, I think they're town wear, I was
inspired by Tom Dale co‑creator of Ember.js
and wearer of PartyPants thankeds Matthewburgman
for the photo.
I figured since I was creating an ember demo
that I would make it related gold pants and
so to make it accessible.
I have could add a caption to these, so, right
now I have existing caption options of Ow!
My eye and shiny.
We could say Tom Dale's fantastic gold shorts,
if I hit enter my little demo adds it to a
list of radio buttons, if I click it, it will
select and because I have bound this attribute
in my amber demo, we can see down here if
the Div tools that it now has an attribute
of Tom Dale's fantastic gold shorts, dynamically
updated without having to refresh the page,
add context to this little demo.
It illustrates that ember can be used to dynamically
attributes, so let's look at some code of
how that worked.
6 custom components in ember are pretty cool,
kind of similar to Angular where but can create
custom element.
The default component is a Div, if I wanted
to spit out a custom element say, PartyPants,
I could change the tag name here where I set
up my custom component, I can change the tag
name.
I'm spinning out a custom element, I is need
to add some area to it.
If I add an ARIA rule, another appropriate
ember will give you, I'll give it an article,
not the most meaningful element ever, but
I can communicate that it's a little more
interesting than a Div.
And lastly, ember will really help you out
with attribute binding, I'm binding a tab
index here, attribute bindings are things
that you can dynamically compute values and
undate on the fly.
In is the ember way of updating attributes.
So, are there places where your framework
can help you do some heavy lifting in in Angular
there are places where we're trying to make
that better.
If you have ideas for other frameworks, by
all means, it's cool to see the stuff help
us out a little bit.
I have an example here of bootstrap, they
have an accord crane group component, it comes
with two properties, is open and is disabled.
Those don't mean anything in ARIA speak, so,
how could we add those.
If I manually add them in line, I could say,
add ARIA expanded of true or false to indicate
whether the accordian is open or closed.
If I wanted to communicate whether it's disabled
or not, this is kind of verbose all of a sudden,
how can I reduce this redundancy, how can
I make it simpler, if you put in a single
attribute, NG expanded or NG disabled and
the framework injected the air are far you
that framework is helping you out, less points
your application could break, things where
the framework is handling it for you.
You might think though it might be useful
if the fame work would detect whether you'd
already add aria, so those are things that
we look at when we add stuff like that.
I mention I've been contributing to Angular's
design components.
A set of styled components that people can
drop into their applications, they weren't
very accessible when I was brought on to the
project, which is why they brought me on to
the project.
It's been cool adding ARIA.
Good example is the radial buttons, they have
pattern, wrapping element, material radio
group element, looks a lot like our PartyPants
elements, it doesn't have semantics, no tab
index, doesn't communicate wait does.
Inside of the material radial group there
are individual components of a material radio
button.
Those don't have any meaning either, so how
do we add that?
Well the real live version of this, now that
I've spent some time with it.
This is simple if Id to reduce the amount
of code to look at.
On the outing radio group directive toker
‑‑ I'm adding a tab index, so you can
get to this control, and I'm wearing a key
down, if you remember our dance button with
the little dog you couldn't fire that with
the keyboard.
If we wire the key down, check if using left
or right arrow then I can fire the events
to change the radio button, if you read the
spec for ARIA, you'll learn that the expected
pattern for a keyboard user is that you tab
on to the control and use the arrow keys to
toggle individual radio buttons, so, that's
why it's important the read the ARIA spec,
so then if we dive down into the individual
radio buttons inside of this parent element,
we can add a road of radio to each individual
radio element, and then we can add an ARIA
label to say what the thing is, we can update
the ARIA check attribute to check whether
it's engaged or not.
Depending on the type of control, with these
it was pretty obvious that there were existing
ARIA patterns that just mapped directly on
to this material component stuff.
But you might be creating more innovative
custom controls that maybe ARIA hasn't established
a pattern, you have to use your subjective
brain power to determine what might be appropriate
for those elements, for those, it was pretty
obvious that the existing ARIA patterns worked
really well, the aid row group, all of that
stuff.
So, that was about it today.
I have some slides, they're on GitHub, short
UL ovinia.cc/MVC‑a 11y,I wrote a Blog post
on auditing a web site for accessibility.
It lists tools and techniques to determine
what's happening with my web site and mobile
apps, that might be useful.
Also the chrome accessibility Div tools are
useful, they can plague problems with apps,
diagnose them and help figure out to fix them.
The accessibility project might be useful.
So, we are going to end with a dance party,
we're in Berlin, when else are you going to
do a German park party.
(I love to sparkle...
) (Applause)